je veux savoir la vie de Fabrice
division sur la déclaration d'Emmanuel
Macron
quand on fait la guerre
chasse à la perdrix
tu devrais pas dire ça jamais c'est une
chose mais il a dit autre chose de pas
oublier les irresponsables ne sont plus
des citoyens alors mon chéri
j'ai plus aucune obligation pas une
société je veux dire clairement sans
droit existe pas ce soir il n'y a plus
aucune obligation
Pascal amendement qui a été déposé on se
sont jetés et donc il peut le faire je
m'en fous mais c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
jusqu'au bout du bout
résidence et de croire qu'il a un
pouvoir sur tout les Français c'est faux
et c'est très facile d'ailleurs je suis
en train de faire quelque chose moi
c'est d'organiser une société
complètement à part complètement à part
de montrer à l'état qu'on a pas besoin
de lui ça se fait déjà aux États-Unis et
ben comme quoi c'est-à-dire
effectivement les gamins parce que faire
du sport c'est pas grave on va se
démerder effectivement par des
personnalités qui ont pas des personnes
privées piscine pour les partager aller
au cinéma pas de problème chez moi
c'est intéressant oui j'ai de l'oseille
et moi qu'est-ce que je fais et ben je
la partage
[Applaudissements]